على كل حال سال الناس في مصر هل تريد
لابنائك ان يحققوا احلامك ام احلامهم
نكتبه
[موسيقى]
يعني بتمنى لهم الخير وبتمنى لهم ان هم
يكونوا افضل ويكونوا افضل مني
و حياه سعيده
ان انا احس ان هم ماشيين على نفس المنوال
اللي احنا مشينا فيه ان الدنيا ما تبقاش
كل حاجه سهله عشان احنا تعبنا عشان نعمل
اللي احنا وصلنا له يعني
اهم شيء بعد لما ياخذ الذرايه مني اكثر بس
عشان انا طبعا تعبت في حياتي جامد جدا
فباظر لازم انصحهم على الحاجات بتاعتهم هم
اقول لهم يعني ايه الصح وايه غلط صحيح ان
كل واحد له حلم في حياته واللي يعني لم
يتمكن من تحقيق حلمه بيتمنى انه يحققوا في
اولاد مع مراعاه
ابن في يوم من الايام كان له حلم الشخصي
او اهداف والشخصيه فلازم الابناء كمان
يبقى لهم اهدافهم الشخصيه وليهم خطه
حياتهم والا يبقى نسخه مكرره من الاب او
من الام
[موسيقى]